So, the name of the course is AI in
science and engineering.
This is the name of the course.
And my name is Sid Mishra. I think some
of you already know me. I see some
familiar faces in the audience.
But I'm a professor here at ETH, and I
work at the computational or I run the
computational applied mathematics
laboratory.
And
yeah, so I'm also an associate faculty
or core faculty at the ETH AI Center.
So, without further ado, let's start the
course. So, today it's all about an
introduction, a very gentle
introduction. We will finish within an
hour.
So, we don't need to take a break.
And just to set the rules, what the
course is about, and so on.
Okay.
So, let's get started.
So, some obvious practical information.
We all know that the lectures are here.
Uh
they are every Thursday from 8:00 to
10:00 or 8:15 to 10:00.
And
as much of you can attend here is fine.
Otherwise, those who can't attend, there
is a live broadcast on Zoom.
And recordings are also available. Okay.
So, we make it as accessible as possible
because there is a cap here of 200
students, and the cap has already been
reached. So, there are people in the
waiting list.
So, if you want to follow the course,
follow it sincerely. Otherwise, make way
for someone who wants to follow.
As I said, the recordings are available
on the Moodle page.
And a key role will be played by the
course organizers, uh Bogdan
and Shajay. They're both PhD students in
my lab.
And they will conduct the tutorials.
This is very, very important in this
course.
So, just uh to set the record straight
from the very beginning, there will be
no exams in the course. This is a
project-based learning course PPL,
right?
And all the performance including the
final grade will be based on project
work.
And the most important thing here
because people keep on asking me
throughout the course is that no
questions about the project during the
lectures or tutorials. You see this is a
master's level course you're supposed to
learn.
And the projects and the exams and the
grades they are a consequence rather
than the main aim.
So point here.
So the projects will be released
approximately in the middle of December.
I think 10th of December is what we're
targeting but it could be one day before
one day later.
And we give you six weeks so you will
have
a four weeks rather because two weeks
are Christmas vacation.
But our usual experience is that two
weeks is more than enough
to do the course to the to the projects
and you have two additional weeks so
middle of January.
But this could be also flexible
potentially.
So what about the course material? So
the course material is entirely based on
the lectures and on slides.
There are no lecture notes per se.
And all the material that we are going
to talk about is based on research that
is uh
in the last three, four, five years so
there's really no textbook to do this.
And what I keep on emphasizing is the
role of tutorials, right? So I advise
this.
And these are the most important ones
because given the sort of condensed
nature of the course there is only 13
lectures
I will not be able to sort of cover a
lot of material in the the lectures so
tutorials are meant to supplement it.
And yeah, I think I have written them
here.
So the course is very broad as you can
imagine. This is I think the fifth or
sixth time I'm doing it so I have some
experience doing this.
So course is called AI in science and
engineering, right? And science and
engineering is a very very broad term.
So, we have to split it into two parts
because there's a distinct flavor to
each.
So, the first part is mostly uh
concentrating on physics and
engineering.
And this is actually bulk of the
lectures. 10 to 11 of the lectures will
be on that. And I will teach them.
The remaining part, which is that
science is not just about physics and
engineering, it's also about chemistry
and biology.
And the techniques that are used are
very similar, but the sort of emphasis
is different.
So, this will be in the second part of
this, let's say the last part of the
course.
And this will be taught by another PhD
student of mine, David Braun.
So, David will take over maybe around
the beginning of December,
end of November.
So, again, I want to emphasize, and this
is very important, that go to the
tutorials
because as I said, the course is very
condensed. I have a lot of material to
cover. And in class, I can only do so
much.
Tell you the concepts, the motivation,
what the algorithms are.
But to implement the algorithms, you
need to really go to the tutorials where
there are lot of notebooks. So, there
are programming demos.
And you can use that.
Uh
any questions so far from the class?
Yes, go ahead.
The tutorials will be recorded. Yeah, I
know many people have had that question
also. Uh they've asked through email.
Tutorials will be recorded, but try to
go if you can.
And it's very important because the
project work is almost entirely based on
contents of the tutorials. And you know,
this is a practical course. You actually
have to implement the algorithms. It's
very important to go to tutorials.
Further questions? Also, people on Zoom,
you can always ask me questions in the
chat box. Okay? So, this is
Okay. So, if there are no further
questions, uh without further ado, let's
sort of take a deep dive into the
content of the course.
Remember that the operative words are
science and engineering, right?
Let's see what what that entails. All of
you are training to be either scientists
or engineers, or sometimes both.
So, you know exactly what science and
engineering entails. Let's let's
take a snapshot of the kind of problems
that we're going to tackle.
So, this is the question. What happens
in science and engineering?
Okay, let's start with a question from
physics. And this All of you know the
sun, right? Without the sun, we don't
exist.
And the sun is a very complex star.
Very well understood star to some
extent. We all We've known all know
about it.
We also know that
bulk of the energy in the sun is created
in the what is called the core of the
sun.
Right here.
This doesn't work.
And there are some nuclear fusion
reactions. Hydrogen atoms combine,
getting to helium, and then generate a
lot of energy.
And this energy this moves through
different mechanisms, right? Through
radiation, through convection, and
finally it reaches the outer parts of
the sun. And these are the parts that
from which the light that we receive
comes, right? And one of the parts
probably some of you might have heard is
called the corona.
The point about the sun is in the In the
core of the sun, the temperature is like
10 million degrees. Okay, so this is 10
million degrees.
But then the temperature gradually
decreases, right? The energy is lost
because there's radiation, there is
convection, and so on. Transport, and so
on.
And it decreases decreases decreases.
Suddenly it comes to the corona, and
then the temperature there is a million
degrees, you know? So, it goes from like
10,000 to a million in like 200 km. So,
this is a very very sharp rise in
temperature.
And even today, even though humans have
observed this for quite a while, 100
years at least,
or maybe even longer. No one understands
why this happens. So, you know, so we
have so many interesting things in
astrophysics. We have black holes
colliding. We have supernovas accreting
and whatnot. But we have not been able
to answer such basic questions. So,
here's an example of what a physicist,
in that case an astrophysicist, would
like to answer
is what heats the corona to a million
degrees, right? No one knows the answer
to this.
And one of the mechanisms which has been
suggested is the better waves that are
being generated in the core of the sun.
Sun has very strong magnetic fields. So,
it's a
gas there is a plasma. And these
magnetic fields, so these magnetic
fields they're directing the sort of the
energy up into the, let's say, the
corona and the upper parts of the sun.
But no one knows, right? So, this is an
example of a problem.
The second problem that I just sampled,
because many of these we'll probably
come back to during the course. That's
why I put a sample of these problems at
the beginning.
Here is another example. Those of you
who are doing climate science, and there
are, I think, quite a few who are
attending the course, they probably know
this. But all of us have seen this when
we take an aircraft and we look down, we
see that there are these belts of
clouds. Okay?
So, these are what are called
stratocumulus clouds. And these are
very, very important cloud type because
all over the world, you know,
we are blanketed by this or carpeted by
this stratocumulus clouds.
The point about stratocumulus clouds is
that depending on the
type, they can absorb sunlight, they can
reflect sunlight. If they absorb
sunlight, that is bad, right? Because
they retain things.
If they reflect sunlight, that's good
because sunlight that's supposed to be
absorbed goes out.
So, they are a big factor in climate
change. But what happens is that when
you have climate change, when the
temperature of the earth increases,
then who knows what happens to these
clouds. They They increase, they can
decrease, and they have a feedback to
climate change. That's why no one knows
for sure if based on carbon emissions of
a certain magnitude, whether the
temperature will go up to 3°, 4°, 5°,
2°. No one knows because no one knows
the feedback of these clouds. Right? So,
a climate scientist, one of the problems
they're interested in, he or she is
interested in, is how are these clouds
formed, how do these clouds react to
increasing temperature, and so on. And
here's an example of a simulation for
the same cloud, right? So, this is a
question that a climate scientist would
like to answer.
And we will probably come to this
question later on.
Here's another example, much more easy
to understand one, because it's it's
very
straightforward in some sense to
comprehend. So, just imagine that you
are in the Mediterranean Mediterranean,
let's say.
And there is an earthquake off the coast
of Crete. So, this is the coast of
Crete, and this is a seismically active
zone. So, what happens when there's an
earthquake? So, the because of the
subduction, the
one layer rises over the other. This, of
course, if you make something under the
under the water, the water level rises
slightly, right? And this will set off
tsunami waves, okay? So, these waves are
going to travel. They're going to travel
all across the Mediterranean.
And the tsunami early warning system
that is used in the Mediterranean, this
is run out of Napoli, that is the
Italian agency which does this.
And what they're interested is in able
to predict or perhaps observe the wave
height. So, as you can see, let's take a
buoy here. So, this is an observation
platform, a buoy in the water.
And they look at how the wave is going
to come, right? So, in the beginning,
the the water level is still, but once
the tsunami probably approaches here,
there's a spike.
1 m is quite a lot, okay? If there's a
spike of 1 m,
which is not surprising the earthquake
happened right very close to it, right?
And based on these kind of waveforms
and there's some issue.
Based on these kind of waveforms, the
agency is going to release a tsunami
alert, which is potential of saving
lives, right? So, what does a
geophysicist do? They have to study this
phenomenon. What causes a tsunami? How
are things evolving? What are the wave
heights? And based on this, they make a
prediction or they make an alert, right?
So, here's an example.
Now, let's switch gears a little bit. If
you are doing engineering,
engineering is all about design, right?
Science is about understanding,
predicting, and so on. Engineering is
much more about design. So, you want to
design a more fuel-efficient aircraft,
for instance. In order to do so, you
need to understand how the air flows
around the aircraft, right? So, this is
an Airbus A380.
Um not the most fuel-efficient aircraft,
so that's why it's being phased out.
They're They're not making new ones,
right? And the one of the reasons is
that it takes in too much of fuel. But
the one One has to study things like
this. One has to study how much of how
the air flows around the aircraft. So,
what is the drag? What is the lift?
What's the skin friction? There's the
pressure on the surface of the wing. And
based on this, one calculates optimal
shape such that you can design more
fuel-efficient aircraft.
Or you can even design a race car,
right? So, if you want to faster race
car, so this is a sort of actual profile
of a race car.
I won't tell you which company, but uh
And then you can see that
based on whether you change the slider a
little bit or whether you change the
front fin, the air flow around it
changes. So, you can have a different
design. So, this is very, very common in
engineering that you need to design.
I don't like when people are talking.
Hello.
Don't talk because it's uh sort of
disturbing to me and it's disturbing to
the rest of the class. I don't have to
say this in this audience, right?
Everyone I assume is at least a master
student, if not
if not even older.
Okay, so then let's go to chemistry for
instance. Let's switch gears. In
chemistry, it's all about molecules,
right? Chemistry is all about molecules
and in particular if you have new
designs, new let's say nano materials.
As I said, we are going to cover
chemistry in the course.
So, you have molecules which have very
complex sort of atom times, very complex
interactions and you want to sort of
calculate different properties of the
molecules. For instance, what is the
electronic structure? What is the What
is the bond structure? What is the bond
strength and so on. There are many, many
interesting questions that one needs to
answer in chemistry.
And even in biology, you have questions
that are
that are there that are quantitative in
some sense. So, here is an example.
And this also happens to us humans, but
when we are embryos. But for a fly for
instance, as you can see, there is a
certain pattern in its wing, right? So,
it has this structure here. It has this
let's say veins and arteries that are
sort of shaping the wing and we try to
understand why this is, right? Science
is all about understanding why this is
and people have for instance done
imaging. So, this is an actual image of
something called a morphogen.
Morphogen.
And you can see how that changes
based on different cells. It changes
with respect to space and based on
values of this morphogen, there are some
cellular
let's say cycles, reactions and then you
get patterns. And people want to
understand how things grow, how robust
they are and so. So, these are some just
selection, random selection. They're not
random because
I could get information about this
because I've worked on all these
problems, but this is what typically
scientists and engineers do. Scientists
try to understand, engineers try to
design, right? So, this is sort of the
leitmotiv in some sense. But, how is
this done? Means how can we sort of
design a race car or an aircraft? How
can we sort of issue a tsunami alert?
How can we understand the dynamics of
the clouds or the development of a fly
wing, right? So, these are the
questions. People want to study these
questions and you want to answer these
questions. So, how is this done?
Right? Okay, I forgot the last example
because I know some people are
interested in finance here. So, even in
finance, which I don't consider strictly
as a science,
but
that's my own personal choice, people
are interested in questions like what is
the right price of a stock option,
right? Because you want to shield
yourself, you want to buffer yourself
against market turbulence,
which is very common these days, and
then you're interested in what is the
price of a stock, for instance. So, all
these questions are there, and the issue
is how do we solve them at this moment,
right? So, you saw very, very
disconnected things. Something from
chemistry, something from biology,
something finance, engineering, physics.
How do these come together? What what
sort of unites them? Right? And the
whole point of the course is that there
is some unity among all these things.
That's why we can use AI methods. So,
how are these solved currently?
So, the first step,
perhaps not a surprise to any of you
because you have been here at ETH or
elsewhere, studying to be scientists and
engineers, is what is called
mathematical modeling.
And this has been around since Newton.
So, Newton was the first to do this. So,
Newton is like 1650s, right?
So, there's been a There is a long
tradition, but I think the best sort of
expression, linguistic expression for
this was provided by Herbert Simon.
So, Herbert Simon won the Nobel Prize in
Economics in 1978.
He was
He was an economist, but at the same
time he was very interested in complex
systems. And he said, "How do you
exactly solve any scientific problem?"
So, this was his point.
Let me just read it. It has such
beautiful language. So, given a
blueprint
This was his point.
To find a corresponding recipe. So, this
is So, given a blueprint or a problem,
you find a recipe or solution.
So, much of the activity of science is
an application of the following
paradigms. So, science and you could
also put engineering here.
Of the following paradigm.
Given the description of some natural
phenomena, so you saw different kinds of
natural phenomena, chemistry, biology,
physics, and so on. So, given the
description of some natural phenomena
to find the differential equations for
processes that produce the phenomena.
So, this has been what Newton introduced
with his Newton's laws and with calculus
and which has been used since
300 years at least, right? And the idea
is that you have this complex processes.
All of these are based on certain uh
phenomena, which are based on certain
processes, which are the outcomes of
certain processes.
And to describe these processes, to
understand them
since Newton, we humans have been using
differential equations, right? So, this
is somehow the language, the
mathematical model in which we are going
to describe
all these phenomena. And this was a
beautiful quote and this was from his
Nobel lecture, in fact.
It was from the Nobel lecture.
Right? Just imagine trying to explain
this to a very general audience, which
includes the King of Sweden, but uh he
clearly tried to do that.
So, essentially when I paraphrase
Herbert Simon, what did he say? Given a
scientific problem, this could be an
engineering problem. It's general. Given
a the problem
find a differential equation describing
it. But I said partial because you see
that this becomes much more important,
but essentially you have to have a
differential equation. This is always a
step one in all these problems that I
described to you, what we do as
scientists and engineers is to write
down a mathematical model, and this
mathematical model is given in terms of
differential equations. So this is
somehow the unifying factor among all
these problems. Let's see if that is the
case. So I have several examples. So
remember that we had this solar coronal
heating problem, right? So what are the
processes that people think is
responsible? So you have flow, right?
Things are moving around. You have
temperature, pressure being changed, and
you have magnetic fields. So you have
the interaction of these three things.
You have
essentially conservation of mass,
conservation of momentum because things
are moving around, so this is Newton's
law. You have conservation of energy
because you have different sources of
energy, and you have the evolution of
magnetic field.
So what this does is that you can
express all of this
You don't have to know the details of
the equation, but I I just like putting
it out. So these equations, these are
called the MHD or magnetohydrodynamic
equations, okay? So what you can see is
that they describe the evolution of a
gas or a plasma in this particular case.
And here this guy is the density.
So you have things moving, so matter
mass is being conserved, so this is the
density. U here is a velocity, things
are moving, so you characterize it by
the velocity.
Then you have energy, right? So this is
given in terms of the pressure and the
temperature, so this is pressure, but
you can think of it as a temperature,
too.
And finally you have
the magnetic field. So B is the magnetic
field intensity.
So for those of you have studied
physics, electrical engineering, and so
on, you know that magnetic field is
given by what are called Maxwell's
equations and fluid flows are given by
what are called Euler Navier-Stokes
equations. So, when you combine them,
you get the MHD equations and we hope to
be able to describe this complex
phenomena in terms of the MHD equations.
So, these are the physical laws that
govern this very complex process. Of
course, it's very difficult to solve
these equations. That's why in that in
this particular regime, so that's why
people have not been able to understand
why this uh solar corona heats up,
right? Because
this is uh not enough or at least our
exploration of this equation is not yet
enough to be able to understand it. But,
the process is very clear. You have a
physical process, you write down a
differential equation, not you
personally, but someone writes down a
differential equation and this is from
Euler, Navier-Stokes, and Maxwell, these
these giants of the field, and then you
describe what's going on.
And you can repeat this process again
and again and again. To follow this
course, you don't need to know these
equations, but it's important to know
that they exist, right? So, this is uh
important.
>> [snorts]
>> So, what about uh cumulus clouds that
affect climate change? How do we
describe them? And remember that I'm In
all these, there are some terms that I'm
not even writing down because they're
too long and they will fill up my slide,
right?
So, what about clouds? Again, the same
thing. You have transport, you have uh
conservation of momentum, you have
conservation of energy, and you have a
lot of thermodynamics, okay? So, because
uh clouds are all about uh
thermodynamics, the laws of
thermodynamics have been known,
the laws of fluid motion have been
known, and these are expressed in these
kind of equations. These are a form of
Euler equations, which were written down
by Euler
in 1770,
when was 1757?
Okay. So, this has been This has uh But,
not these particular equations, but the
original equations were written down by
Euler, who is probably the most famous
uh Swiss scientist, most well-known
Swiss scientist. Again, the same
process, right? You have some complex
phenomena and you can encapsulate it by
just a set of equations, which anyone
who knows the subject can immediately
identify it, right? So, this is a very
parsimonious, very succinct description
of what's going on.
Uh let's take another example, the
design of aircraft, flow around an
aircraft. It's slightly different from
the flow uh that describes the cloud,
the the sort of thermodynamics that
describes the cloud, because here it's
not so much about the temperature, it's
a lot more about the velocity. And these
are really the Euler equations or the
Navier-Stokes or you can also say
Navier-Stokes equation.
Again, so the this these are partial
differential equations because your
objects that you're describing, for
instance, the density rho is a function
of space and time, right? So, it changes
because when the things flow, it sort of
changes. So, this is another example,
and we can go on, like what happens in
chemistry, for instance, this is another
very very very famous equation,
Schrödinger's equation. This is 1925,
right?
Around that time, so about 100 years
before during the birth of quantum
mechanics, Schrödinger was able to say
that everything is anyway described in
terms of a wave function.
And this wave function tells us the
probability of finding a quantum
particle at a certain location and at a
certain time. And then all of chemistry
and a lot of physics is based on the
Schrödinger's equation. And of course,
you have to model the Hamiltonian and so
on, but that's that's not my objective
here. The objective is that there is a
differential equation, and this
differential equation takes the form of
a partial differential equation because
again, this is a function of space. In
this case, the space is given by an
abstract space, the positions, the
momenta of each of the quantum
particles, and by time, right? And even
biology, right? So, as I said, means
everything that is describing processes
is described by differential equations.
So, even in biology, you have these
equations, and I put it here because I
derived them, so.
So, that's why I am I'm very proud of
having at least derived one equation.
They they are fairly straightforward,
but they describe the same sort of
processes. So, you have things changing
in time, in this case cellular
concentrations, you have things
diffusing out, so this is diffusion,
there are reactions or degradation,
there's transport, and you can you can
sort of write them down, right? So, this
is everything can be described within
this paradigm, even even options, right?
And in fact, the equations that come up
are Black-Scholes equations. They won
the Nobel Prize for economics in turn at
some point because they were able to
write down equations which describe the
price of a European option for instance,
right?
So, again, we don't need to know the
details of all these equations, but the
common structure that emerges out is if
you go back to this quote of Herbert
Simon which said that, "Okay, you have
processes, you have differential
equations to describe it."
Essentially, what is describing them are
not just differential equations, but a
particular type of differential
equations, and these are partial
differential equations.
Okay, so this is sort of the
key point that at least I will cover for
most of the course. So, now by just
giving these random snapshots which came
up from different domains of science and
engineering, it is easy to see why
partial differential equations are
called the language of nature.
Okay? Because, of course, this is a
human construct, it's not like partial
differential equations or differential
equations something out there, something
tangible. It's how we describe the world
around us, right? So, instead of saying
some blah blah blah blah blah about a
fluid flow, I say it's described by this
particular equation. That is a saying
very condensed, only accessible to those
who understand what the differential
equation is about. So, which is just as
just as well.
So, just like we have natural language
to describe, I don't know, daily events,
like I woke up in the morning, I took my
bike, I came here, I'm talking in front
of you, I'm looking forward to my
breakfast that I missed. So, this is
this is sort of natural language, right?
So, in here what we do is we describe
scientific language in terms of
differential equations. So, this is an
important point that there is a
universal description or universal
descriptor, rather, which is available.
And just to repeat that you have immense
variety of physical processes that I
just showed you, all the way from the
tiniest atom, right? So, an atom or an
electron. So, this is what are what are
the physical scales? Who can tell me
what is the what is the length scale of
an electron? Let's see how much of
uh physics you guys know.
Who can tell me length scale of an
electron?
Just approximate.
Yeah?
10 to the power what?
10 to the what?
Electron?
Length scale?
So, how how how how big it is?
Yeah? Yes.
Minus 12.
Actually much less, minus 18. But you
are you are in the ballpark, right? So,
minus 18. So, this is in length
or volume or whatever you call it. Time,
right? It also moves, right? The
electrons move, they they circle around
and so on. Any guesses? Similar, 10 to
the minus 18, okay? So, these are tiny
tiny tiny objects. That's why we have
a lot of electrons inside our body, for
instance.
And who can tell me at the other end of
the scale, means what is the scale of
the universe in terms of meters or
whatever?
So, what's what's the scale? What are we
talking about? Length? Yes.
Yeah, 10
100 million light years, 15, 10 to the
15, right? So, roughly speaking, 10 to
the 15. So, you have, you know, minus 18
to 15, that's 33 orders of magnitude.
And time, similar, okay? Similar length
variations in time. So, you have
phenomena, at least our description as
humans of phenomena, going all the way
from that of subatomic particles, you
know, even below electrons that are what
are quarks and gluons and whatever they
keep talking about in particle physics.
And all the way to the whole length of
the universe, right? So, this is
There are also people doing
multi-universes, but at least in our
universe, we have huge scales that that
are there. And everything in between.
So, this is all the way from here to
here, but everything in between. So,
when you are at the level of a
molecule, for instance, or a group of
molecules, then the length scales
increase. At the level of a fly or a
human embryo, you have different length
scales, different time scales. At the
length of this,
let's say, this table, if I if I try to
put some force on this table. This is on
a beam, but
if I put force on the table, you have
different descriptions, different length
and time scales. At the length scale of
an aircraft, time scale of an aircraft
is different. And then you have Earth,
you have stars.
Goes all the way into
the universe, right? So, there's a
immense variety of length and time
scales, immense variety of processes.
Things are moving, things are slow,
things are fast,
big, small. All of this is described by
partial differential equations. So,
these are really universal descriptors,
right?
So, that is that's a good argument. And
just because we are going to use them
all the time, because remember, this is
the language in which we describe
science, in which we describe
engineering. So, this is we need some,
let's say, cursory knowledge about them.
And the important point here is that the
unknowns,
I will correct the echo. There is an
echo. But uh
the unknowns are U, which is a function
of X, space, and time T.
That's why these are partial
differential equations because you have
partial derivatives that come in, right?
So, X here, this belongs to D, the
domain. This could be the room here if
you are describing heat in the room or
sound waves uh when I'm talking to you.
And time, of course, is um time.
And this U can mean anything. This can
be pressure, this can be temperature,
this can be whatever, displacement,
concentration,
whatever object that you want to
describe, right? So, this is a This is
an abstract description of many, many,
many different things.
And what we do essentially in partial
differential equations, since Newton, he
had ordinary differential equations cuz
he's only looking for variation with
respect to time,
is that you have a bunch of partial
derivatives. You have UT, you have the
gradient of U, second derivatives,
second derivatives, third derivatives,
fourth derivatives, and so on.
And you can relate all these things
together in terms of physical laws,
right? So, there are some examples which
are coming up in a minute.
So, essentially the abstract form of the
PDE
is just a relationship between all these
different derivatives, partial
derivatives.
And that's why you have
uh partial differential equation. Okay?
Any questions? As I said, uh you can
always ask questions. That helps me.
Yes, go ahead.
Yes, of course, uh it can be complex. I
just made it very simple. So, uh
Schrödinger's equation is a typical
example where you deal with complex
quantities, right? So, of course, it can
be complex.
Um
we can do that, but we probably not.
Maybe you're giving me some ideas for
projects.
Maybe good.
Of course, we can do it complex Complex
uh
to describe physics. You need complex
numbers, right? We already know this. So
maybe maybe one minute.
Maybe I will not say it in class, but
there will be a project on complex value
differential.
Further questions, more ideas for
projects?
Okay, that's true. Maybe we
you won't know about
it. Okay, let's
So these are the PDEs and as I said, I
gave you several examples of these. You
don't need to know all of them. It would
be good if you know something, right?
But what's the issue?
The issue is whenever you have an
equation like this, you want to find the
solution.
But we know that this is far from the
case, right? I can give you a very
even an algebraic equation and you can't
give me the solution of an algebraic
equation. So how on earth are you going
to write down a formula to solve this
very complex equations? Let's revisit
Let's revisit one. Even this one.
You know, I tried very hard to find some
analytical solutions. It's very
difficult to find them, right? And just
even you go further like something like
this, let's go there. This is
impossible.
You cannot find an analytical solution.
You cannot write down a solution
formula.
Except maybe in the simplest possible
cases.
So this is the issue. We we can model
everything and we can write down the
equations, but then solving them is
extreme challenge, right? So this is not
possible.
And I'll tell you a sort of a funny I
don't know how many of you have read The
Briefest History of Time. I mean this is
a sort of a
Not many, huh?
I'm dating. You know, when I was it was
released in 1994, I was 14 years old and
that was one of the reasons why I
decided to do science. It's so exciting
for me, right? But you know, when
Stephen Hawking what he wrote down was
uh
you know, we are going to understand,
we'll have this theory of everything.
Everything is going to be described. So,
I was thinking that by the time I grow
up, the theory of everything would be
done, and then there's nothing to do.
There's no science to do, right? But, in
the very last page, he says, "Yeah, so
what happens is the physicist's work is
to write down the equations."
But, then you have to solve these
equations, and this is uh very different
ballgame altogether.
So, then the the idea to write down is
the first thing in the process, but you
also need to solve it, right? And then
it becomes very, very difficult, and uh
we cannot find out explicit solution
formulas.
So, what we do instead is that we use
what are called numerical methods,
or some approximations. You know, even
with uh I think this is known since
antiquity, but uh even Euler,
Navier-Stokes, Maxwell, all of them, to
solve the equations, they would use
approximations. But, since about 1920s,
the approximations are what are
methods. Methods.
Just just
Hello.
I think the audio is doing its own
thing.
And now suddenly No, it's coming back.
Okay.
I'll deal with it afterwards.
So, now the point is that uh So, what
are What are numerical methods? Uh So,
all of you must have some familiarity
with them if you've done the basic
courses. So, the idea is that you have
an approximation. You can't get an exact
solution of the PDE or the differential
equation. You have an approximation, and
this approximation is something that you
can It's an algorithm, so you can write
it down as an algorithm,
which can be implemented on computers,
right?
So, instead of doing the hard work of
calculating the solutions ourselves, we
let the computer do the work. And there
are ton of these methods, right? You
don't need to know all the details, but
perhaps some of you know the names. So,
these are finite differences, finite
volume methods, finite element methods,
spectral methods. So, these are sort of
great achievement for the last century
of human knowledge because we have these
methods, and once we have these methods,
you will see in a second, we can solve
those equations, these very difficult
equations that are out there, right? So,
maybe I have some examples. No. Yeah,
maybe I start with an example just to
describe what these methods are. This
course is not about these methods. This
course is about replacing these methods,
right? Or augmenting them, but it's good
to know what you are confronted with.
So, this is a very simple example for
those who don't know.
So, this is the heat equation, you know?
So, what is the heat equation? What does
it describe?
Okay, who can tell me who derived this
equation? Who was the first person to
derive this equation? General knowledge.
Does anyone know?
Fourier.
Yes, someone said it on Zoom. Fourier.
So, this is Fourier.
Do you know the story of why Fourier
derived this equation?
So, Fourier was officer in the French
army. This was a Republican army under
Napoleon, right? Napoleon himself was an
artillery officer, so he knew very well
that math is very useful because then he
could put his cannons in the right
place, and then the cannons will fire,
he knew the trajectory and so on. So, he
encouraged scientists to become officers
in the French army, and Fourier was one
of those people, very bright guy, young
at that time.
And what Fourier wanted to solve is that
the cannons were getting too hot, and he
wanted to calculate the heat based on
different conditions. And he came up
with the heat equation. I think the
cannons kept on being hot because this
was not a linear transport linear
equation, it was a non-linear equation,
but we all got Fourier series, Fourier
transform, and sort of science was
revolutionized. So this comes from
Fourier. It describes the diffusion of
heat, or let's say that you have a dye,
and you put or you have water and you
put a dye, and this dye is all diffused
out, right? So this describes diffusion.
So U here is just a scalar quantity.
Think of it as concentration or
temperature.
And we are in one space dimension, so
but we have time, right? Things move. So
the dye is spreads out, the temperature
moves, and so on. And this is the heat
equation.
And Fourier derived an approximate
solution of this heat equation. That's
why he came up with Fourier series, but
that's another story. So you have some
initial conditions, you have some
boundary conditions. Boundary conditions
are that the things are zero, you have
ice on both sides, for instance.
So what is the idea behind a numerical
method? We we we can in this particular
case find an analytical solution, but
we're not going to do that. So instead
what you do is that you have This is
your space, remember?
space
And up here is time, right?
So what you do is your space-time
domain, this is a continuum.
No continuous quantity can be put into a
computer. So what we do is we divide it
into points, and this particular case it
will be cells or whatever. And these
points are for instance based on some
equal distribution in space, and let's
say for simplicity there's some equal
distribution in time, right? And yeah,
so this delta X and delta T are the mesh
size and time step, right? So instead of
trying to find the solution of the heat
equation for every single point in the
domain, what we're doing is that we're
making our task easier by just finding
solutions on the so-called grid points,
right? So points uh
So this point and this point and this
point, all these points, right? So
instead of having an infinite problem,
uncountable problem, we have reduced it
to a finite problem. But, we know as
this delta x and delta t becomes smaller
and smaller, this mesh becomes a denser
and denser, and more and more points get
approximated. So, that's the basic idea.
So, now for a fixed delta x and delta t,
so we are going to find the solution.
So, let's call this as
Sometimes difficult to write down, but
yeah.
So, I even have it, v n j, right? So,
let's use this, v n j. Oh, gosh. What
happened here?
Change the
So, this guy here, and we want to update
it. So, what we do is that we know that
the heat equation has two sets of
derivatives. So, you have a time
derivative, u t, and you have a space
derivative, u double x, right? So, this
is a second derivative in space. So, the
time derivative is approximated by some
forward Euler, some forward difference.
It could be backward difference, means
it doesn't or
it could even be central difference.
But, for simplicity, we have a forward
difference. So, this tells you that to
calculate the solution, the time
derivative here,
so, all that I do is I take the value
here, take the value here, subtract
them, and divide by delta t, right? So,
this is a very simple approximation to
the time derivative.
And what about the space derivative?
I'll use a central difference because
it's a second derivative. So, the value
here, you take this guy, you add it with
this guy, subtract with two times, and
you divide. So, this is a very, very
simple thing. This is how we learn
calculus, right? We take this finite
differences and we pass through the
limit. That gives us derivatives. Here,
you invert this process,
and we know that the time derivative
equals the space double derivative. And
we When you put them together, you get a
very, very simple
algorithm here. So, this is what is
called a finite difference scheme, okay?
And this is the simplest possible
algorithm that can describe or that can
approximate the heat equation or any
differential equation, right? So, when
when things become more complicated,
then this this becomes much more of a
science.
So, as you can see here, this is a very
straightforward thing. You can go to the
computer, you can write down a Python
code that does it in microseconds as
such. It's very, very simple.
But almost immediately, you see that
there are some some problems. And these
problems is what I wrote And this is, of
course, before that, I must say that all
the problems that I wrote down before,
whether it's the flow past a race car or
the
you know, the cloud formation and so on,
all of this can be sort of done with
these numerical methods to some extent.
So, for instance, in astrophysics, this
is just from my lab, right? So, me and
my collaborators, my students, we've
done these simulations. So, we could
simulate clouds, supernovas, or
tsunamis, or flow past rockets as
examples, just using techniques like
this. Of course, much more advanced
versions of this, but essentially
techniques like this. So, this is
extremely successful.
So, everything that we do today, all
engineering, a lot of physics, is based
on these kinds of simulations.
But there are some intrinsic problems,
and let me just address these problems
so that we understand what we're trying
to do. As I said, we don't take a break
today because from next week onwards,
we'll take a break at this time. But
today it's first lecture, it's sort of
we we'll finish within 15-20 minutes.
So, let's just stick on, right?
So, now essentially, if you remember the
algorithm that we had, it had two
parameters, so the time step and the
mesh size, right? So, for those And then
you need to relate them. You need You
need some stability conditions, you need
to relate them.
So, essentially, I'm not going through
the derivations here, but just to
compute the amount of compute that we
need, it scales in terms of the number
of mesh points,
which depends on the dimension, right?
So, in 1D you can have 100 points, in 2D
it's 100 by 100, so that's 10,000. In 3D
it's 100 by 100 by 100, which becomes a
million and so on. So, it scales with
dimension. Each of these points you need
to update, so it scales with dimension,
also number of time steps, and so on.
So, eventually what you get is that
this is the scaling that you get. So, to
get certain amount of error, your cost
of compute it has to grow in this
manner. So, let's try to put some
numbers here.
So, let's say we want to get 1% error.
So, for those who do engineering, this
is the magic number. We always want to
get 1% accuracy, relative accuracy. So,
1% is 1 over 100, right? So, this is 1
over So, this is 1 over 100, which means
that 1 over 1 over 100 is 100, right?
So, this is 100 times
So, 10 to the 2 * d + 2 / 2. So, this is
10 to the d + 2.
So, if you're in one dimension, your
compute is like in some non-dimensional
units is 1,000, which is which is not a
problem.
But, in two dimensions, it starts
getting 10,000. In three dimensions, it
starts getting 100,000 for the heat
equation and so on. So, your compute
scales with dimension, right? So, if you
have a problem which is in 100
dimensions, like sometimes you have to
solve the heat equation in 100 or 1,000
dimensions,
then you're out, right? Because there is
a growth exponential in dimension.
And there are such problems, you know,
you think that everything is
three-dimensional, but that is not the
case. For instance, the problem with
stock options, it depends on the number
of stocks, the dimension is the number
of stocks, and this can be 100 or 1,000
or 10,000, depending on what is your
portfolio. So, there are many, many
different examples of this. So, for
those who know, as I said, Black-Scholes
for options pricing, this is typically
of the order of a hundred to a thousand.
And Schrodinger's equation, you know, it
describes electrons and quantum
particles and so on. This could be even
higher dimensional. And then there are
some Boltzmann equation and so on which
are six or seven dimensional. So this is
These methods completely break down for
such problems. And you'll see some
examples of that later on in the in the
lecture.
But what is even more interesting to
some extent is that even if you consider
low dimensions, so low is like D equal
to 1 2 3.
This is what we humans can comprehend,
right? So 1 2 3, so we can comprehend
that. Even then these kind of PDEs
always can be very expensive. So I'll
give you an example. So this is
Navier-Stokes.
Navier-Stokes equations, this is
describing fluid flow. So this is some
initial conditions. The solution
evolves. As you can see, it's a very
very complex solution. We'll revisit
this problem many many times during this
course. Okay?
And to simulate it at a very high
resolution, there are reasons why you
want higher resolution here. So this is
thousand cubed, okay? So there are
thousand points in each direction, which
means that there are a billion points
per time step, but there are many many
variables. It's like five billion points
per time step. And then you're going to
evolve it over time. And this is a very
expensive proposition.
If you want to do it on CPUs, even on a
supercomputer, this takes you 5,000
hours. That's not surprising. 5,000
hours
at this high resolution. But if you have
abilities to code up in GPUs, this goes
down by factor of 50. So this is
approximately 100 hours.
Okay? So this is still an expensive,
computationally expensive point. But the
issue here is that
again you you'll have to learn this in
this course.
And for those who know, they already
know that these are very chaotic
systems, you know? So minor minor
changes, tiny tiny changes in the input,
so in this case the initial conditions,
you can barely see these changes, right?
So, these are the inputs, tiny changes.
If you sort of squint, you can see a
slight difference, but the solution, it
changes dramatically, right? So, there
are these dramatic changes in the
solution.
So, in some sense, you cannot use sort
of deterministic methods for this. You
have to do what is called uncertainty
quantification, which is very very
common in engineering because things
change, you have some uncertain
information, you're not sure of the
initial conditions, you're not sure of
your boundary conditions, so you have to
do many many different simulations.
And many many different simulations is
something, right?
And when you sample, this even if you
sample uh
100 times, it is expensive, but you have
to sample like a thousand times to
generate some meaningful statistics.
So, now you do the math, right? We have
We were like 94, right? So, 94,000, so
it's almost close to 100,000, and this
is expensive. 100,000 on supercomputers
is a very very expensive proposition.
And this is the issue because if you
just had one simulation and we are done
with it, our life would be relatively
simple. Even though to design such a
simulator, it took a PhD student several
years, right? But it's still
let's say the final cost is not so much.
But here, the final cost is a lot
because you have to do many many many
different simulations.
And whenever you deal with design, this
is the generic case. Let me give you an
example. Again, this is an example that
we are going to revisit many many times.
So, this is shape optimization. Uh
design is all about shape optimization,
right? So, what do you do?
So, this is just in 2D just as an
example. You'll see the 3D version of it
in a second.
So, it's an airfoil. We have flow past
an airfoil. You know, we all fly, so
airfoil is a section of the wing, right?
And then when the flow comes and you're
looking at cruise conditions, you have
the formation of a shockwave here and a
very complex flow around the airfoil.
You want to design an airfoil such that
your drag is small or your lift is large
or the drag to lift to drag ratio is
large and so.
So, how do people do How does a designer
engineer design such an effort? So, you
start with a generic design.
So, which is uh you you don't start from
zero, you know. I I don't take this
bottle and say, "Okay, from here I'm
going to design an airfoil." Right? This
is not going to happen. I start with
some well-known shape. All of us know
that
uh airfoils have to be streamlined,
right? Because without streamlining, you
can't do this.
So, you start with something
and then you define a design envelope.
So, there are different parameters. In
this particular case, there are 20
parameters, if I remember, 24
parameters, if I remember it correctly.
And then, what the designer does is that
you start with a
start with the shape, calculate the flow
around it. So, this is this
this point here. So, you call a PD
solver. It's in 2D.
So, with the solver that we designed
in-house, this takes about a minute,
okay? A little more than a minute, but
less than 2 minutes. It's not on GPUs,
it's on CPUs. So, it takes about a
minute. Just not so bad. It's 2D, it's a
minute.
But, the point is then you calculate
some gradients with respect You want to
see what is a good direction in which to
go with the shape, right? So, you
calculate some gradient descent.
And it's often done using what are
called adjoint methods. Uh but, that's a
detail. So, you have flow, you calculate
the gradient with respect to the flow.
The simplest way would be to compute a
finite difference, for instance, and
that would be two two x uh so, it would
take about 2 minutes to do that.
But, the point is to do this design,
I need many many many different steps.
So, here is, for instance, my initial
design.
Here is an optimal design. This one is
an optimal design. Very very tiny
changes, as you can see. But, the drag
it reduced by
many many, I think a factor of two or
something.
And but it took me how many iterations?
This is 4096
yeah, 4096 iterations.
4096 iterations, so which meant that I
have to multiply this two minutes with
4096. That's what the process takes,
right? And this is sequential. You
cannot parallelize it. Well, this is a
gradient based method, you cannot
parallelize it. There are some ways to
parallelize.
But essentially whatever I do, I need
hours and hours or in this case many
many days even, right? To do this very
very simple design problem. So no one
actually designs for so long. You stop
somewhere, say okay, this is good enough
and I stop.
So again, the point is that each
individual call to a PD solver can be
expensive, particularly 3D, but the
point is we have to do it again and
again and again. These costs are going
to blow up, right? And here is an
example, right? So this was a 2D
uh Roy sandbox example, but when you go
to a real design problem, this is as I
said a car company which designs Formula
1 cars, and this is an actual shape and
they want to sort of optimize this.
For them, the even the naive simulation,
it takes about 500 node hours per shape,
right? So for us it took a minute
because we are solving a 1D problem 2D
problem, but a full 3D car, even the
sort of not very accurate simulation, it
takes 500 hours.
So there's no way that you can sort of
iterate. You can't do
the 4096 simulations, each of them
taking 500 hours, right? So this at the
moment they don't do this. They have
some heuristics, they do some
simulations, some heuristics, and so on.
But again, the point that I'm trying to
make is this repeated application of the
PD solver. It takes takes takes quite a
quite a while.
Another example, I have a bunch of
examples, but I don't have to go through
all of them. So, this is an inverse
problem.
So, essentially, many of the problems
that you deal with are inverse problems.
You'll see that in the course. In other
words, we want to calculate what is
inside this black box by sending in
waves. Okay, now this is not even seen,
but by sending in waves and by measuring
the reflections, we are going to
calculate what is in. So, what is in is
essentially this. This is again a toy
model.
And this is what the PD solver gives me.
But it takes quite a or quite a while.
It takes about 9 hours. You know, in 2D,
in 3D this is again not tractable.
And so on and so forth. We have many,
many examples, but maybe I don't need to
I need don't need to talk about them.
So, what is What is the bottom line
here? The bottom line here is that we
need to solve
Okay.
Doesn't matter. So, solve PDs
much faster.
Not just fast, but much faster. You
know, because at the moment,
particularly this example tells you
that if it takes 500 hours to just
simulate flow around one shape, and if
you can bring this down to a minute or 5
minutes, how much more the design
process will be accelerated, right? So,
in a way, designs are very conservative,
primarily because people don't know what
the implications of the designs are
going to be. So, this is a very, very
important point. We have this lovely
sort of machinery or pipeline to
understand nature, to design, which is
based on writing down equations, and
then solving them with numerical
methods. It works very well till we
realize that as we try to scale it up,
it breaks down, right? So, it takes it
takes too long to solve these PDs. Is
this point clear? So, this is the first
rationale that we need for alternatives.
Do we have any questions so far?
No?
Everyone understood this?
Okay, we'll find out
later on.
Okay, so what is the second rational?
So, the second rational is even more
sort of important and it's a very subtle
point. Generally, I don't have the time
to sort of uh emphasize this enough in
the course,
but this time I will uh because this is
where it is getting.
It's so, what is the pipeline? The
pipeline is you have some phenomena,
right? So, you have some phenomena, you
know the physical laws or someone knows
the physical laws, you write down PDEs,
you solve them numerically,
right? And then make some predictions,
uh do some adjustments, and so on. This
is the process of science.
But the point is that in many times
we assume that all the physics has
already been known, right? So, if you if
you talk to physicists today, they only
want to work in string theory and
high-energy physics where the physics is
unknown. They believe that the human
scale all the physics is known. So, you
can write down the equations and you can
solve them by numerical methods if not
by analytically.
But let us take something uh very
concrete and try to illustrate this,
which is our Earth system, right? So,
this is our Earth system.
Our system is a very complex uh thing.
Let's take this. So, this is our Earth
system, very complex one
because there are many many forces at
work, many many processes at work here.
So, we have the flow of the atmosphere
and the ocean, the wind flows, and ocean
currents that is flow there.
We have radiation which comes in from
the sun, get absorbed by clouds and by
by various mechanisms. We have the laws
of thermodynamics. The physics of these
things is very clear. Flows in the
atmosphere and the ocean as
Navier-Stokes equations, uh some form or
other.
Thermodynamics, the laws of
thermodynamics, right? You know the
first law, the second law of
thermodynamics, and these can be
incorporated in terms of equations. And
then the radiation, radiative transfer.
We again know this uh so, if you have
done some basic physics, you can
yourself write down this equation. But,
the problem is that this is not enough
because our earth system also has land,
right? So, okay,
80% is water, but the remaining 20% is
land. And then this land absorbs the
heat, it radiates heat, it has processes
that it involves that it's involved
with, particularly forests, right? So, a
lot of the world is forests,
unfortunately being cut down all the
time.
But, who can write down a differential
equation for a tree? Right? You cannot
write down the differential equation for
a tree. You cannot write down the
differential equation for a forest or
for a bunch of forests. Then land has
the same effect, vegetation has the same
effect. Then in the atmosphere, you have
aerosols, you have tiny particles, you
have
ice, you have sea ice, and so on and so
forth. And this is a sort of a Herculean
task to write down equations for all
these processes, and people give up. So,
they do sort of heuristics. You cannot
sit down like in physics 101 class and
derive all these equations. So, what
does what do I mean? So, when you go to
the real world, the idea that we know
all the equations, we all know all the
physics is simply bunkum, you know, it's
simply not true. And this is because
there is some missing physics.
A lot of it is missing, and this are
some examples. So, this is
for instance
the flow in a reservoir under the
ground. So, you want to put in some
carbon dioxide and let it sink. Again,
no one knows what exactly what is the
physics that underlines this.
In our brain, for instance, who knows
what goes on? Means the laws are still
particularly the biological feedbacks
are not clear at all. This is traffic in
the city of Zurich. We assume that we
can write down equations, but there are
many, many undetermined things.
The point that I'm trying to make is
that
it would be great if you knew the
physics, but we don't know all of it,
right? So, instead what we have is those
who have done robotics know this. It's
called Sim to real gap. What does it
mean?
It means that you have a physical
system. Right? You can write down some
equations to describe it. You can do
some simulations of the type that I just
described. And then you do some read
outs and see aha, so this is a system's
response. Then you do some measurements
of the system. Okay? You've done very
very accurate simulations. You do some
measurements and there is a gap between
them. And this gap is what is sometimes
called modeling error.
And this is sort of
you can't change this. Right? This is
order of one as we call it. Okay? And in
when you go to the real world when there
are multiple processes that are
involved, this is always the case. You
do a simulation and you think that you
look at the system correct but the
response is not correct. Right? And here
the point is that by having better
solvers, better numerical solvers,
faster solvers, even if you have the
fastest solver on earth, this problem
will not go away. Okay? Because this is
something that our sort of human
understanding of nature breaks down.
Right? So when our human understanding
of nature breaks down, there's no way
that we can solve these kind of
problems. Okay? So here the PD is simply
unknown. Unknown PDs.
So either we need to solve the PDs very
fast or we don't even know them. So this
is these are the two sort of pillars on
which the rationale for finding
alternatives exist. Okay? But for all
these
cases, what we have is data.
Okay? Forget about operators, but we
have data. We can make measurements.
Right? For the earth system we have very
very precise data. For many of these
processes we have some data and we have
getting increasingly more data from
sensors, from cameras, from probes, and
recorders and so on. right? So, the
question is that does this sort of
pipeline of
understanding science since Newton,
which is there's a phenomena, some
genius sits down in a room, write down
writes down the equations, and then
someone comes up with the numerical
algorithm, someone else implements it.
This is sort of breaking down because we
have either they can't scale it up, or
we simply don't have enough
human brain power to write down the
equations for every process, right? So,
this is breaking down.
What is not breaking down and what is
increasing in scope is data. The
question is can we marry these two
together? Can we take the existing
physical knowledge that we have and
combine this with data? And this is
precisely the rationale of this course.
This is what I really want to do, and
this is the aim of this course, right?
So, it's essentially it is to learn
physics.
Physics is a vague word, right? It
describes all science and engineering
and so on, but
I'm a physicist myself, so I say
physics, okay? And the it's modeled by
PDEs. So, we know that in principle we
could write down PDEs, but sometimes in
practice we can't, but what we have is
data. So, these three things come
together, physics, physical knowledge,
PDEs, data. How do we sort of combine
them together? And this is going to be
the main sort of content of this course.
And just to give you a preview of what
we are going to do is the last element
of the course is AI in science and
engineering, right? So, this is where AI
comes in.
So, this is the age of AI, we know that,
right? We know the reasons why AI
succeeds is first of all we have more
compute.
Second, we have more data, much more
data these days, and this is just
increasing in scope, in content, in
volume. And finally, we have these
magical objects,
neural networks or deep neural networks,
with which we are able to process this
data, right? So, now can we take these
three things, go back to the previous
slide, and see whether data which is
already there,
and compute
which hopefully we have, and then
finally deep neural networks.
Neural networks. Why didn't that work?
Neural networks.
Can we sort of combine these ingredients
together to learn physics?
And this will be sort of the main
meaning of the course, okay? And I'll do
it over the next 10 lectures, but
we already start with something on the
in the next lecture. So just as a
practical question or practical point,
Monday there is a tutorial. So they're
going to start a little bit with neural
networks in that in those tutorials, so
that you're already primed, and it's
essentially about PyTorch, so that you
learn how to use PyTorch and so on. I'm
not going to cover that during the
course, but that will be covered during
in the tutorials. So in the next
lecture, what I'm going to do is we're
going to do a deep dive into neural
networks. I think many of you know this,
but just for the sake of completeness
and notation, I'm going to do that. And
then eventually we get how to use neural
networks to solve PDEs, but that that
comes later. Okay, so are there any
questions so far, or
no?
You can always ask me offline. I'm
available for some more time. So then,
thanks a lot for your attention, and see
most of you, if not all of you, next
week. Okay.